c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
alors j'étais en vacances à et oléron
mon grand-père d'une maison rapidement
et je m'étais embrouillé avec une petite
amie du lycée
et vous pour m'aider pour l'avs ai passé
deux trois jours sans se parler et aux
91 jours m'appelle il dit oui mon gars
tu comment on fait en fait une fois
qu'on est sur l'île pour arriver jusqu'à
chez toi comment ça en fait il avait
pris la voiture il dénoue justin sans
savoir vraiment où j'étais sur cette
région de la france et des mieux
chercher à passer toujours magnifique
parler d'une mon pire souvenir de
vacances d'été remonte à l'été 1997
j'avais alors six ans presque dans cinq
ans nous étions avec mes parents et ma
famille sur la plage était simple bigné
et
déjà un petit mot com et alapage dois je
commencer avant l'été du coup j'ai
demandé à mon père si je pouvais aller
regarder le concours de trampoline
chronicles étant donné que nous
serviette été installés juste devant un
public et oui les ivoiriens des ponts
cours de trampoline et tu te payes pas
me voilà devant des sauteurs en
trampoline pas plus passionnant que ce
qui se passait sur la plage et donc je
me suis dit bon mais les attend de ma
famille au parc ou de quoi donc je
prends mon petit saut et je m'en vais
d'autres aventures il attend j'attends
j'attends on avait dit qu'on partait
dans paris tend donc à temps quand même
assez longtemps mais bon je me promène
spa france autre chose et là je vois mon
oncle qui harrison parking et qui hurle
à mes quatre metella ne cherchez pas
tout et tout ils pleurent rient pleurent
c'est papa de deux petits contente de
retrouver et en fait mes parents étaient
persuadés que jamais distingué sur la
plage du medef est kidnappé par un bref
ma mère arrive à le prendre dans ses
bras
l'état arriver oui jimmy choo évidemment
et voilà samassa a traumatisé ça m'a
traumatisée de padt ne pas avoir une des
consciences en fait que je pouvait
inquiéter inquiété par an et que les
peines soient tellement énergique 1 300
magasins étaient au podium
[Musique]